hello everyone welcome back to another
Collider interview straight from
Sundance 2019
brought to you by Kia Telluride a huge
thanks to them right now we have the
filmmakers behind the movie share here
Rianne Pippa thank you so much for
coming in and a huge congratulations on
the film first whoever wants to do it
can you tell our audience briefly what
share I know you've probably been asked
this a million times I watched that
question get bumped around from person
to person because no one wants to do it
no share story of Mandy Brianne barreto
a high schooler who gets a video from a
night she doesn't remember and then sort
of has to unravel what may or may not
have happened while navigating the
escalating chaos and fallout around it a
first feature for you which is just a
huge achievement can you tell me a
little bit about getting not just saying
one morning oh I'm gonna make a movie
but actually feeling like it's real like
what was that thing that changed that
conversation you know I think it's like
a small cumulative thing I mean I think
I came to it more from a place of loving
films I don't think I necessarily I
studied like photography and painting
undergrad and that was what I loved
doing and then I was like I'm super
lonely this is very lonely pursuit and I
want to work with a team you know with a
crew what art forms are there with more
bodies film was the only thing I'm not
musically talented in anyway or a dancer
so film was absolutely I get nervous
about silences so I will fill them in a
karaoke setting with just harmonizing
regrets but no I think it was that it
came from a place of like just wanting
to you know work with the team and you
know in a collaborative art form and
then it was small incremental I think
kind of things steps from there like
piei jobs from off Craigslist I was
looking at your filmography on IMDB and
I saw Bachelorette on there and I
happened to see Leslie headland here the
other night and I loved Bachelorette I'm
a big
her so I found it funny when you can
connect the dots there yeah I was a PA I
think that was like my first job out of
college it was like I was PA camera PA
terrible camera PA I'm mostly just
coiled and uncoiled BNC cable that's it
that's like where it all starts though
and I'm also a firm believer that
whether you're a director or any
position on a film at all just having
that understanding of what other
departments have to do can only help the
overall production I think so I mean I
think there's no there's there's you
know especially writing and directing
it's like you're responsible for every
every choice whether you like it or not
it's no one to blame so I think that
having like a physical grasp of you know
whether it's poster you know any arena
it's like really empowering and and
expands your toolkit you know expands
the palette you can paint with like you
know some familiarity with my new chef
with B&C changing the end of BNC cables
a new chef we obviously have to jump
into the casting process because I was
reading that it was pretty extensive and
you obviously have a wonderful lead here
so how how did this happen I was reading
something like did I make this up 500
auditions or something like that you
didn't yeah well you know I mean for me
the film is pretty much entirely on
space it's you know it's not it's not a
performance that it's a very I think
nuanced and subtle it's a really
challenging performance I think and it
was very specific and there wasn't you
know I just had to I saw incredible
talented people but I think finding
someone who could you know carry the
they're really emotionally you know
challenging scenes the big scenes the
heart you know the ones that were gonna
be exhausting and painful but then also
being incredibly gifted athlete and be
up to the physicality of the role yeah I
was reading that you learned to play
basketball and the second I saw that I'm
like oh we're gonna get along I'm
obsessed with basketball that's growing
up my favorite sport really is what was
your position like what was your thing a
shooting guard and point guard
but yeah and I still love playing now
anytime I have the opportunity to talk
1v1 I will ref I wish it's like I
wouldn't go out in the cold for just
about anything it could boss basketball
its head of puffy no no that would be a
very entertaining video what was it like
jumping into your first feature -
especially as a lead because I imagine
it's this wonderful opportunity you're
grateful to have but I also imagine it's
probably like nerve-wracking oh yeah
definitely I think it was absolutely
terrifying in in every sense of the word
because I'm not American I'm not a
basketball player I'm not I'm not Mandi
like I just I don't think I I wish I was
and I I don't know if I could make the
strong choices that she made in the film
I think I'd be crumbling on the floor a
lot crying and eating I think I'd eat
more than to press up so anything I deal
with things with press ups I think I
think you're not alone with deities to
sandwich a sandwich but family has
biceps that doesn't exist in my body but
ya know so I it was a crazy process I
think there was there was this problem
with the visa
I couldn't basically couldn't get to
America because of probably my race I
was told I didn't look British and my
visa got denied and that was a couple
weeks right away from shooting and yeah
I mean we did appealed I think we five
times we made five different attempts I
mean she was denied no one I mean she
was granted the l1 you know she like
they deemed you qualified for the
artists visa and then went in for the
interview and had a really problematic
racially charged interview yeah because
my dad's background in Iraq so that
happened that gave me time and stress
and a lot of emotional experience to
understand
Mandi I think I think I kind of used I
had to you you have to just use all this
pain sometimes I think as an artist it's
like feed into this suffering because
I'm not a survivor I'm
never had mandis experience and it was
an experience of powerlessness and and
and a lot of things happening at me and
people telling me to do things that they
thought was right for me and this
feeling of blame and being it being my
fault which mandy experiences and I
cannot I am I do not and I'm not
comparing this to it survivors
experience because it's not that and I
cannot imagine the pain that they go
through but nor can I imagine a real
refugees pain and suffering and this was
a vanity project in comparison to I
think trying to survive and be a
baguette into a country for your family
not being in a cage you know like it's
bigger than this so yeah so that
definitely fed into it yeah very that's
a very upsetting story to hear yeah I'm
glad to hear that you use that
experience in a positive way to serve
the art and now you're here sharing a
movie with a lot of people out here who
the movie could probably help them
hopefully I mean this was pepper being a
legend and not recasting mean like
moving a different to a different
country for one actors like I'm not I'm
not in any I'm not famous I'm not even
here though come on I've got no like
credentials just wait I'm just like eat
the microphone I don't know what to do
what is that conversation like from your
perspective with your producers because
I don't know your specific producing
team but is that a decision that they
embraced or did you have to do some
convincing especially with financers
involved to make sure that you made the
movie with the person you wanted to make
it with yeah I mean we there was I think
any responsible producer financier would
make you have a conversation about that
you know because it was obviously like
you know very you know we were in a
movie with a lot of resources or extra
resources certainly so I think it was
like a real it had to be a considered
decision for me it was a no brainer and
I really feel everybody else felt that
way too and one because Rihanna is so
singular and I there was no one else who
could carry this film you know who could
inhabit this role so fully and so
beautifully so for me non-starter there
it was like we're moving where she can
work but also I think we all felt and
producers financed here's to you know a
24 was really
really supportive that like someone
shouldn't lose their job because of the
way a visa interviewer thinks their skin
looks so I think it was like you know if
we think that that's not cool then how
could we support a policy like that so
we went somewhere where we could all
work which happened to be Canada they
gave us all visas but you know I mean we
got really lucky you know I think after
the film came out there was you know
like a revived effort to get me his you
you know weren't gonna be allowed to
come to Sundance we couldn't get her
even an s touch I was refused in US
senator Kirsten Gillibrand wrote a like
an impassioned plea to like it you know
the records released for for Rihanna I
have interviews and they granted her
Senators had to get but like this really
lucky we're really grateful the time ago
like from England I'm privileged I've
got all this money behind me like all of
these incredible people and I can't even
get into a country what about the people
that really need it like they don't have
money that they need to live it's a
story I think a lot of people need to
hear out there and the same goes for the
actual content in the movie because I'm
seeing a lot of movies at Sundance this
year where someone can walk away and
maybe they didn't have that exact same
experience with that exact same
challenge but by seeing somebody else go
through it they can realize new truths
about themselves and I really appreciate
that so what do you hope that viewers
take away from your movie when they go
home at the end of the day you know I
mean that's a that's a beautiful
question and a complicated one I mean I
think I hope that they you know simple
answers I hope that you have empathy for
a choice you maybe wouldn't make you
know that you can understand how even if
this were you know how one could make
that choice but I think also to find you
know a lot of dignity and heroism and
the everyday something that we thought
about you know that like Mandy's
character isn't one who you know the
story is in many ways a small and
intimate story about like deeply
personal small choices and crises and
you know in confrontations and I think
that Rianne beautifully embodies the
strength and the self determinism and
the dignity
in those small choices so I would hope
that you know it also you know people
are given an opportunity to celebrate
those small choices you know in just the
heroism and people who are in pain
getting up and out of bed every morning
and moving the world with their own you
know sense of purpose and and
deliberation Thanks I pay her a 24 I
here the movie was so actually you could
shed some light on this what was the
process like a finding out that you got
distribution is that something that
happens on the spot as we get the report
from the trades or do you know about it
going into the festival uh I would say
this happens quickly there's a lot of
intensity but no you know a 24 is like
it's partnering with HBO on it so it's
in some ways like we knew going in
because we were working with a 24 that
there was an already a distribution plan
in place HBO coming on as part of that
piece of the time that is really
liberating it also allows you to make a
lot of riskier creative choices because
you're not as worried about who's gonna
buy this who's gonna find this
commercially appealing you know you're
like what is the truth of the story I'm
telling and how can I do it best so that
was really liberating and empowering but
yeah I think it also gave us you know a
certain amount of relief because we have
so much confidence in them and then when
they told us like hey look you know
there's another person we'd like to
really partner with who we think can
give us a whole new platform of you know
of ways for people to experience this
film we thought that was really cool so
a 24 is a company that I greatly admire
me do an HBO as well yeah we're really
looking the the content we get from them
do you have any idea when everybody out
there is gonna be able to see the movie
or is that kind of details or I think it
will be this year okay
well very very helpful sure in that case
I'm gonna urge everyone out there to
keep an eye out for the movie share and
thank you all for watching this
interview like and share it tell
everybody you know about this movie and
a huge thanks to both of you for being
here
thank you to Kia Telluride for making
these interviews happen we will see you
soon with more Sundance